as an elite athlete growing up there
there was always a stigma but behind
mental health if you're weak if you
asked for help and I always felt like
the physical issues were looked after
much better like the second you get an
injury they're like rested I said see
this doctor go to the specialist you've
physio and mental health while it's not
Universal has always been a little bit
on the look down on side and I really I
went through it myself and I really feel
like it's so important especially when
you start a such a young age to just
have that support system there was
nothing there are so many athletes it's
been very recent that like it's coming
out though they have eating disorders
physical abuse mental abuse especially
in the non team sports it's it's much
easier to prey on those who are weak and
I think all of this ties collectively
the same goes for lgbtqia+ people they
need their own unique forms of support
and it all ties together and compounds
to make all these issues seem big in
your head and sometimes reaching out for
help is very difficult so I want to help
provide platforms where it is like a
system of support just like we have for
physical well-being for athletes